direction présent la tunisie qui fait
face dans certaines régions un problème
d'accès à internet au nord-ouest du pays
certaines populations isolées se sont
exclus face à des élus dépourvus de
moyens matériels et financiers l
approche d'une consultation nationale
reportages signés ben hassen chébili
avec les airs nasri et ahmed senhadji
[Musique]
ingram un paradis écologique niché dans
les montagnes du nord-ouest tunisien
semble comme figé dans le temps derrière
ce paysage de carte postale se cache une
toute autre réalité celle d'une région
l'une des plus pauvres du pays en pleine
consultation nationale alors que les
grandes villes tunisiennes enregistrent
des taux de participation 300 depuis le
15 janvier ici rares sont ceux qui ont
pris part à cette initiative
gouvernementale
pire encore dépourvues d'accès internet
certains n'ont même jamais entendu
parler de ce projet cher au président
sayed une série de questions sur des
thématiques tels que l'économie la
culture l'éducation le numérique ou
encore l'emploi indispensable selon
carthage pour mener à bien les réformes
attendues par les tunisiens consciente
de ce handicap les autorités ont annoncé
la mise en place d'ordinateurs dans plus
de 270 maisons de jeunes sur tout le
territoire national
objectif inclure le maximum de tunisiens
dans ce processus de sortie de crise à
la maison de jeunes de aïn draham en
dépit de l'installation de six
ordinateurs ce questionnaire n'attire
pas les foules voilà ici c'est l'espace
dédié à la consultation nationale comme
vous le voyez les ordinateurs sont déjà
installés dans cet espace qui est à la
base la buvette de la mjc là où se
réunissent principalement les jeunes de
la ville dans cette région la majorité
des personnes ne sont pas au courant
généralement ce sont ceux qui sont
équipés d'internet les populations
cultiver les jeunes les étudiants toutes
ces personnes sont au courant de cette
sultats sion mais ceux qui habitent un
peu plus loin dans les campagnes et dans
les montagnes eux ne sont pas au courant
a kid hormis cela nous avons constaté
qu'il n'y a pas un réel intérêt
dans cette région montagneuse où le taux
de chômage atteint les 25 6% la
population comme les collectivités
locales semble avoir perdu espoir un
constat que fait nadia mazni nerfs de
aïn draham qui par manque de moyens et
de directives peine à faire exister
cette enquête nationale auprès de ses
administrés
vous savez pour nous ici concernant
cette consultation nationale nous
n'avons reçu aucune directive des
autorités que ce soit en terme de
campagne de communication ou même de
logistique aucun panneau publicitaire
aucune campagne de sensibilisation
ici ce n'est pas comme à tunis nous
sommes une petite collectivité et la
plupart de nos administrés n'ont jamais
entendu parler de cette consultation
à mon niveau je ne sais pas comment
porter cette information la population
je pense à travers le site de la mairie
où grâce aux associations locales
ici les associations semblent s'être
substituée aux collectivités locales
comme ultime contacts entre tunis et ses
régions oubliées actif dans le milieu
associatif de pipi de 15 ans sabri se
bat chaque jour pour maintenir auprès
des hommes et des femmes de sa région un
sentiment d'appartenance d'existence en
tant que tunisien et citoyens à part
entière un autre en tant qu'association
nous avons organisé des tournées à la
rencontre des populations les plus
reculées et nous nous sommes rendu
compte que la plupart des habitants
n'ont aucune idée de cette consultation
nationale et quand nous leur avons posé
la question ils nous ont répondu qu'ils
n'ont pas accès à ces informations
diffusées principalement sur internet et
certains nous ont même confié
qu'internet c'est quelque chose dont ils
entendent seulement parler quand je leur
pose la question est ce que vous savez
ce qu'est la consultation nationale ils
te répondent automatiquement qu'est ce
que c'est que ça et quel est l'intérêt
de connaître ça si ça ne changera pas ma
vie ni mon quotidien le seul fait que
dans consultation nationale il y as
nationale nous poussent à poursuivre
notre mission par le biais de rencontres
pour expliquer à la population rurale le
but de cette consultation la façon d'y
participer d'utiliser cette application
pour créer en eux un sentiment
d'existence comme citoyens à part
entière une mission délicate reflets
d'une toute autre réalité celle de ces
ruraux qui ont l'impression d'être
exclus du système
personnellement cette consultation je
n'y comprends rien je n'en avais même
pas entendu parler et ces choses là
n'ont jamais été quelque chose qui nous
intéresse j'ai entendu dire qu'il
fallait une connexion internet pour
participer mais nous n'avons pas
internet une chose de plus qui prouve
que nous resterons toujours les exclus
la seule chose que nous souhaitons c'est
que notre quotidien change vous savez il
y a des gens ici qui vivent dans une
grande précarité
vous pouvez voir par vous même quasiment
tout le monde est au chômage ici nous
sommes trois générations à vivre dans
cette petite maison et on n'a rien vu ni
de casser l'idée précédent gouvernement
pour améliorer notre vie vous savez je
vais être honnête avec vous si cette
consultation change quelque chose dans
ma vie je serai avec lui sinon c'est le
dernier de mes soucis
alors que près de cent mille tunisiens
ont donné leur avis sur la plateforme
dédiée la consultation nationale dans le
gouvernorat de jendouba dont un drame
fait partie moins de 2000 citoyen
participer sur les 47 mille que compte
ce territoire un triste constat qui ne
finit pas de mettre en exergue
l'exclusion persistante de cette région
au processus de transition démocratique
de la tunisie